c'est non non monsieur le président oui
mais bah oui d'ailleurs surpris mesdames
et messieurs les jurés public adoré que
nous dit car mars dans la dame aux
camélias
je connais la réplique au fioul ou tommy
haas camélia est d'abord est ce bien de
karl marx
la dame aux camélias et 6 non et si
c'est bien tard mars
est-ce que ça s'appelle vraiment la dame
aux camélias dit loulou tommy d'air
camélia aux incertitudes
nous ne savons rien mesdames et
messieurs les jurés pauvre fourmis
misérable que nous sommes nous ne savons
rien nous ne savons pas si dieu nous
regarde nous ne savons pas si
l'apocalypse est proche
nous ne savons même pas si c'est pas non
qui va gagner ce soir un autre autre
version en tout cas dans ce livre
sublime dita louloute mythe des camélias
l'auteur car loi repos que 16 ne cessait
de glorifier la nécessaire amitié franco
allemande que le misérable carell roger
ne cesse de ridiculiser sciemment dans
une débauche d'hystérie convulsive anti
germanique primaire ans qui nazisme
primaire même drt is good habermann tu
as its klein l'amitié franco-allemande
est le plus sûr garant de la paix en
europe écrivent et schopenhauer et il
ajoutait
et il ajoutait courtis talking to draw
superbe automne chocraux de garde ni
varrault c'est à dire vive de gaulle et
encore et encore il ajouté est plus loin
online prout prout is paulette et mon
cul c'est du poulet
[Applaudissements]
depuis cette époque hélas les ennemis
viscéraux de l'amitié franco germanique
se sont déchaînés sans répit contre
l'idée d'une grande europe qui irait de
berlin à perpignan et de bonnes à nice
tandis qu'au sud de la loire après
dissipation des brumes matinales
d'éclaircies un micro sur l'ensemble de
nos régions récit quelques températures
relevées sous abri ce matin à 5h 5
degrés à paris pardon s'il termine 6 ans
et lisez pas le journal 6° à rouen 1
environ 20 ans 3 euros donc c'est clair
rejet car elle est coupable
tout petit déjà mesdames et messieurs
les jurés sept hommes cherchaient à
nuire à l'amitié franco allemande
lors de la signature de l'armistice
solennelle de 1918 projet car elle qui
avait à peine 35 ans avait eu l'immense
honneur d'être choisi pour servir
d'interprète entre les représentants des
vainqueurs et les représentants des
vaincus car il était alors estafette
bilangue hui l'un d'entre eux
[Rires]
quant au moment au moment de la
signature en prenant dit qu' eu lieu on
s'en souvient dans le fameux wagons du
train corail le capitole bresse béziers
l'atmosphère était chargé il face aux
plénipotentiaires allemands le aubert
truman fureur manille et l' auberge
combat ne purent boum boum fureur
bettoni les généraux français ne pouvait
contenir une légitime fierté et on les
comprend c'était une magnifique victoire
avec du sang plein les rivières et
pratiquement autant de morts des deux
côtés le pied bref il était la face à
face ennemis d'hier copains de casino
demain collabos après-demain et
l'atmosphère était tendue cette victoire
les vaincus ils avaient à coeur et les
vainqueurs la veille dans le cul
l'atmosphère était tendue certes mais
jusque là pas vraiment désastreuse car
on était finalement entre gens du même
milieu qui partagent traditionnellement
de siècle en siècle le même goût pour la
musique de chambre
le champagne et les concours
d'équitation d'internationaux la guerre
ne l'oublions pas la guerre est faite
par des gens qui ne se connaissent pas
qui s'entretuent pour le compte de gens
qui se connaissent mais qu'ils ne
s'entretuent pas c'est pas moi c'est
plus petit c'est c'est peut-être landes
et lot puis en 2007 le village
enfin bref l'atmosphère était tendue
l'accusé car elle ici présents qu'ils
avaient à peine 55 ans et qui assistait
à cette dramatique entrevue aurait pu
d'étendre facilement l'atmosphère grâce
à sa paire de langue nous parlions tout
à l'heure mais il n'en fit rien
l'officier prussien vaincu s'approcha
des représentants de la france
le colonel de la boucherie et le général
sus mes preuves et il dit
et d'y goûter narbonne mind gijon tu vas
voir ta gueule en 40 les passages
traduisit roger carel quelle ambiance
par la suite roger carel s'est quelque
peu amendé persévérant dans le
bilinguisme c'est lui qui doublent
généralement de sa belle voix chaude
les nageuses est-allemand championnats
d'europe c'est lui également qui faisait
de gaulle dans la version allemande de
l'appel du 18 juin à laquelle m oregon
faisait allusion l'autre jour à rôle
avant à perdre une baballe manama
verdine la guerre c'est drôle je demande
à l'encontre d'orange lui car elle une
peine de 20 ans de prison militaire si
possible avec obligation de
perfectionner son accent russe afin
qu'ils puissent faire la voix de brefs 9
au journal de gicquel
quand les soviétiques ont regagné la
troisième guerre mondiale tête non non
[Musique]